destins croisés arnay-le-duc la maison
régionale des arts de la table rend
hommage aux deux fondateurs de ce musée
unique en france en 1981 les bâtiments
désaffectés de l'hospice saint pierre
construit au xviie siècle ont trouvé une
nouvelle vocation grâce à pierre meunier
maire d'arnay le duc amis de jean moulin
secrétaire général du conseil national
de la résistance et à son ami de longue
date
henri moisan il faisait partie tous les
deux de la commanderie les cornes en
bleu de france dont qu'ils avaient
l'occasion de se retrouver très souvent
tous les deux et c'est au cours d'un
déjeuner à arnay-le-duc au restaurant
des terminus qu'affectionnait
particulièrement pierre meunier qui se
sont rencontré pierre meunier voulait
faire de cette maison un musée et henri
moison qui était directeur la faïencerie
de longchamp et de plus le président
fondateur du comité national des arts de
la table dont ils se sont retrouvés pour
se dire et bien leur en faire les arts
de la table
le musée fête cette année ses 40 ans
mais en 2019
il a frôlé la fermeture mis en vente par
l'ancienne municipalité
le bâtiment a fait l'objet d'une
proposition d'achat par un investisseur
privé
on s'est battu avec beaucoup de force
avec des pétitions avec cette envie de
résister et donc apparemment là je crois
qu'il est sauvé parce qu'on a quand même
les élus qui sont en appui qui sont qui
sont derrière nous pour nous soutenir
association loi 1901 la maison des arts
de la table disposent de peu de moyens
mais c'est exposition attire chaque
année dix à onze mille visiteurs la
nouvelle municipalité a des projets pour
consolider l'avenir du musée et l'aider
à se développer c'est le rôle des
collectivités aussi de soutenir ses
actions
et puis également dans nos zones rurales
d'amener la culture directement aux
habitants ouverte 7 jours sur 7
l'exposition qui met à l'honneur cette
année de la faïencerie côte-d'orienne de
longchamp se terminera le 11 novembre